joining me right now on the on our uh
mercedes-benz vans phone line is none
other than my good friend ian rappaport
from the nfl media group how are you ian
what's going on rich how are you i'm
fine what's the status as you and i are
talking right here right after noon on
wednesday um with urban meyer and
jacksonville best you can tell well
he at best i can tell he's still
jacksonville's coach he has addressed as
you mentioned team
in full uh he described himself as
someone who embarrassed both the team
and his family
he said that he takes full
responsibility he talked about
basically how he failed the team and how
he should not have done what he did
it was
you know a couple minutes long um i
think it was necessary it was important
you know how did the players take it
like i don't know
but
needed to be said you know i don't think
they're gonna try less hard on the field
um you know and also their own force so
there really is nowhere to go but up but
i think it was necessary i haven't heard
any change in his job status i think the
you know remarks by shad khan a prepared
statement by shad yesterday were
extremely noteworthy like i
i i honestly can't remember an owner
really saying anything like that
i mean that was a very strong public
rebuke and it was not off the cuff so he
is still the jacksonville jaguars head
coach but
you know i would say very clearly been
put on notice
i i i i'll be honest with you i cannot
believe that this is the way the first
four weeks played out in jacksonville i
just i'm i i'm trying to you know
compute
that a ceo head coach
who has nothing but winning on his
resume
um
just on the football field obviously off
the football field there's lots of
apologies that urban meyer has been
forced to give in his career but i i
still cannot believe
that the conversation of whether he and
his
team can trust
him
or that that that management and his
team
is questioning their trust level in him
i i that one i i i would never have
predicted never would have predicted
that would agree i did not see of all of
the
um
of all of the nfl scandals i did not see
this coming on my bingo card
um
i've seen many of them for a lot of
weird very strange things but this one i
did not see coming i honestly
can't even remember any circumstance of
a player not flying home with his team
or a coach shot by home in this team
like i guess it probably has happened
i've just i cannot think of any off the
top of my head well i mean in that
regard ian i mean he said today urban
said today that trent balkey the general
manager who was hired after him um and i
imagine was hired with urban's uh
blessing right i mean that's the way
these things go in the nfl when you hire
somebody of urban final say on our
football and on a higher so right so
that that that you know you still have
to be able to say urban you you you know
you do that
and
it's you're you're opening yourself up
to so many problems i would counsel you
not to do that don't do it or
something has to be done right yeah i
imagine some form of accountability that
that would be a blind spot in the in the
um
in the flow chart that the khan family
probably didn't see coming right i mean
that that somebody would consider that
that's just i mean
you know shad khan like all owners is
very rich um has
use of a plane
um
urban meyer said like
you know
i got tired man like it's been a long
grind like i really need two days
can i borrow your jet to go to columbus
after i fly home but you know he would
have given it to him right
right or or the amount of money that he
makes from the khan family i mean that's
what mike lombardi mentioned yesterday
it's just like hey you know
it's an inconvenience an extra what
eight hours of plane travel but at least
you fly back with the team and then you
wake up the next morning and you go you
know you're tired when you're around the
grandkids but
i i i again you know i'm sure if urban
could wave a wand he would he would
realize but do you let's just say this
and then we could put a button on it uh
what is the rest of the nfl community
that you're talking to about your job i
mean are they all asking you like what
what are you hearing in jacksonville are
they just as shocked as we are oh no
they're no they're telling me everything
that they're here in jacksonville
okay like
everyone
everyone has
a coach that they know or an executive
that they know who's heard
about
you know all the things in jacksonville
and and you know
this happens
when
things start to kind of spiral out of
control everybody wants to weigh in and
i think like as a you know as a reporter
um you sort of have to be careful
because
one of the weird things in our world is
when someone comes into it like urban
meyer from the outside world the college
world i think it's fair to say there are
a number of people who really would just
like him to fall in his face and fail
um we thought this was a ridiculous
thing for jacksonville to do and thought
he has no business in the nfl and those
people are very happy right now um i
don't know how this is going to end
uh recent the recent days sort of
suggest this might not end great but but
we really don't know they have a great
young quarterback and that's a great
place to start
um
but there are definitely people who are
sort of celebrating this and doing the i
told you so and then saying hey by the
way have you heard about this other
terrible thing in jacksonville so
not a good time to be a jaguars person
um
but if they win a couple games and
trevor starts to show the promise that
he showed thursday night
uh this probably all goes away
interesting uh and rappaport here uh on
the rich eisen show
so
um very rare do we see
just flat out cuts
in between weeks four and five of an nfl
season of players who
one would think have some trade value um
but
walk me through the two uh surprising
releases starting with
jalen smith in dallas does this have to
do with the joneses don't want to be on
the hook for next year if he gets hurt i
mean what's going on with him right now
all right let's start start with jalen i
think the main thing but they they tried
to trade him before the season they
offered teams to eat all the salary but
the minimum
um they they tried to trade him a bunch
um you know i think it's clear his
salary kind of outpaced his performance
he is not a starter in dallas wasn't
going to be this week i think leighton
van der roush has come on
and keanu neal who makes a lot less
money but has played a lot better is
basically the starter so it's going to
be van der resch kean o'neill and then
mike parsons doing many many fun things
on the football field
and jalen on the on the way out um
and it was going to be kind of on the
sidelines and
you don't want a disgruntled veteran not
playing in your locker room and you're
gonna pay the money anyway
um but yes the reason that they can't
trade them
is because the nine million dollars in
injury guarantees next year that's
almost like a you know
that you almost can't do that
um
so i think that's that's one thing like
i mean he was you know the name is a big
name
but
it was not a surprise that he was
roommates like they been trying to trade
and deal with him for quite some time so
he's not a starter in dallas but there's
got to be a bunch of teams that say we
can use him i mean in significant teams
like i mean
well not everybody has a linebacker like
dallas does either right so i mean
we're and again i know this is could be
like fantasy football type uh
conversation because it's just like well
this team could use him sure looks like
it but it might not be a scheme fit or
anything like that i mean you're talking
about the chiefs having such a difficult
time stopping people and you got
somebody like jalen smith out there and
now also stefan gilmore we'll get to in
a second where do you think um where do
you think jalen smith winds up first
blush well you know i would say
kind of like you would think the teams
that need linebacker so we're talking
you know
you know mike the packers have a need
there possible washington
um just lost prospect for the season
might they have a need cleveland browns
have had some injuries
um
the las vegas raiders have had some
issues have linebacker i think they'd
always like to get better and the best
thing is so jalen smith it's not good
for the cowboys but it's good for
everyone else um they're paying his
whole salary this year so jalen makes
his money so he's gonna sign for the
minimum
because
dallas is paying a salary so
you're gonna get a good player very
cheap
i bet i mean so that's gonna be a robust
market for him and why is stefan gilmore
i mean we heard about the hold in right
instead of the hold out what was going
on with him and then you know pop and
the whole business with him with new
england we we've been seeing this
divorce coming for quite some time why
why now why release for him now and what
it i imagine his market will be quite uh
significant as well
as a free agent uh i think a couple
teams will be interested in him yes um
now his his release has not happened yet
and that is worth noting i mean
belichick has said goodbye
gilmore has said goodbye
um
they do intend
to move on from him
but you can trade him up until 4 p.m
today
so a lot of times when news comes out
very early in the morning
you know it comes out with everyone
keeping all you know all doors open um
so by the patriots making clear they're
going to move on from him if the team
wants to trade for him they could
definitely do that
um so i would definitely keep an eye on
that um you know i think this
relationship really ran its course i
mean the patriots were willing to give
gilmore
a couple million dollar bump on his
salary they wanted to make sure he was
healthy first he hadn't practiced never
because he was on the public
gilmore
wanted to get paid
wanted a bump in salary
and wasn't going to practice until he
was able to do that and i couldn't
figure out for the life of me how this
was going to end
because
those two things do not compute
so it's probably best that it ends this
way
because
i i didn't see any other resolution
especially not one that satisfied both
the patriots and gilmore
in rap report here on the rich eisen
show 844 204 rich number to don once
we're done with ian uh give that front
load and we got a couple more minutes
left with my colleague from the nfl
media group look it's it's just you know
it kind of feel like i'm on uh uh you
know a habit trail in a way when i
mention the subject of desean watson
where we just keep turning around and
around around look we have no idea
what's going on on the legal front we
have no idea what's going on in the
investigative front we have no idea
about a ton
the only thing that we know is that
there's nothing on this green earth that
will cause the texans to call him up and
say you got to play
or put him in that position or deshawn
watson is going to call up the texans to
say you know what you know i've had
enough of
what you see on my instagram account
actually right it almost hurts them if
you play so so the question though is
the trade deadline is i believe just a
little bit less than a month away than
right now yeah so
where are we is there is there any there
there because there's just so many hints
being dropped that there's smoke no fire
but there's you know that there you know
nick casario would actually consider
giving you pick protections now so on
and so forth where do things currently
stand should we be paying attention to
this sort of thing
i mean you should always pay attention
because if it happens it could happen
very quickly um i haven't sent anything
imminent at all i know there's been a
lot of rumors um i pay attention to all
of them
um
i make calls on
all the time
i haven't sensed anything imminent with
the sean martin um and maybe there's
something going on that i don't know
about i just
i have not sensed it um i think a trade
could happen i think it could happen
during the season i think that would
make sense
um
you know i think his legal situation
like you said is still very much up in
the air we'll see what happens with that
um but the same problem persists
you know he's never going to play for
the texans again
so the longer nick cereal holds him if
he can deal with the
uncertainty of not trading him and like
clearly he doesn't care
because he's dealt with it already
then if you just wait until the off
season doesn't the market get bigger
can't you get more
aren't you going to know what you're
trading you know what picture getting so
it's just
i know everybody wants it to get done
and believe me i want it to get done so
so badly so bad
um
so badly
no it's not that i want i want it to get
done i'm just
knowing that there are so many teams
whose fortunes would change instantly
and that there are teams that you know
by waiting just even by waiting right
like for instance and i know this would
be completely out of character for the
steelers to do
but the the urgency for pittsburgh right
now
um and the thought that they would could
even twitch in a direction like this
right now would be different than say
next march wouldn't it
wouldn't you think
um
i mean it would change their season yes
but
then it's like i mean first of all come
in new system you already have been
there it would only make sense if you
basically do not have a quarterback
because then like he comes in he
practices for two weeks splitting reps
with ben
like i just
that's hard to fathom
um it's
i don't know that's why i said it's at
it that's why i said it makes sense
that's why i said it's out of character
i mean look and then he'd want he'd want
to have to go that's the only reason why
i i bring it up is that just you know it
would totally change
the concept of what a season would look
like for whichever team acquires him on
the spot
but the problem for the texans would be
is the draft choices that they get
would instantly get worse because right
deshaun watson would play and start
winning
so right because he's a very good
quarterback yes i've heard that
yes so and that's why i mean
i've never seen a situation like this it
is
absolutely incredible um
but this is why there are so many
different layers to it
i guess that's the perfect way to end it
because that's the conversation starter
we had with urban meyer never seen
anything like it there's nothing to
describe it and uh it's crazy
ian it really it really is all right
thanks for the time really appreciate it
we'll chat again soon
all right look forward to it take care
let's see ian wrap report at rap sheet
right here on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here